l ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de monsieur antoine lefèvre à
madame le ministre de la réforme de
l'état de décentralisation et de la
fonction publique
monsieur le président madame la ministre
en octobre de l'année passée j'ai
présenté un rapport au nom de la
délégation territoriale du sénat sur
l'évidente enjeux de la formation aussi
bien des élus que des agents
territoriaux le droit à la formation est
une des conditions de la démocratisation
de l'accès aux fonctions politiques de
même l'enjeu technique et professionnel
de la formation des fonctionnaires
territoriaux est tout aussi évident ça
nécessitait forte dans un contexte de
consolidation et de diversification des
compétences des collectivités
territoriales mais aussi à un moment où
l'état se retire progressivement d'un
certain nombre de missions qu'ils
exerçaient il exerçait dans les
territoires la mise en oeuvre de la
formation des agents publics locaux est
ainsi confié de manière exclusive pour
certaines d'entre elles au centre
national de la fonction publique
territoriale au titre de sa principale
mission obligatoire je souhaite donc
attirer votre attention sur le nouveau
dispositif de financement des frais de
transport pour la formation des agents
territoriaux assurée par ce cnfpt
précédemment la participation des
collectivités s'élevait à 1 % de la
masse salariale avec prise en charge des
frais de déplacement et d'hébergement
des stagiaires par le cnfpt ensuite
cette participation était réduite à 0 9
9% mais les collectivités devaient
financer les déplacements depuis le 1er
janvier 2013 donc alors que la
participation est revenue 1% le cnfpt ne
reprend pas totalement à sa charge les
frais de déplacement les montants des
remboursements variant dorénavant en
fonction du mode de déplacement retenu
le stagiaire qui utilise son véhicule
personnel sera remboursé de 0,15 euro
par kilomètre à partir du 51e km celui
qui se déplace en transports en commun
le sera à hauteur de 20 euros par
kilomètre dès le premier kilomètre en
cas de goût voiturage le conducteur de
la voiture utilisée remboursé à hauteur
de 0,25 euro par kilomètre à partir du
51e km et enfin la collectivité peut
prêter un véhicule de service auquel cas
il ya cumul du 1 % et de la prise en
charge financière du déplacement les
conditions d'application de ces barèmes
sont donc défavorable à la fois aux
agents mais également aux collectivités
cette situation ne semble pas
satisfaisante en particulier pour les
pôles les petites collectivités en
milieu rural et accentue encore plus les
disparités entre les départements
urbains et les départements ruraux en
effet ces derniers sont par des films
s'ils ont moins bien desservis par les
transports en commun le département de
l'aisne que madame la ministre vous avez
eu l'occasion de visiter il ya quelques
mois ne dispose pas vous le savez de
liaison ferroviaire nord-sud alors que
la distance sur cet axe est de près de
160 km c'est donc très nettement un
nouveau transfert de charges vers les
communes je vous demande de bien vouloir
examiner la possibilité que les frais de
transport des agents en formation soit à
nouveau pris totalement en charge par le
cnfpt d'autant que dans une réponse à
une question écrite du 11 novembre 2012
il avait été indiqué que je cite la
restauration à 1% du taux de la
cotisation dès 2013 devrait permettre au
cnfpt de réviser les restrictions du
programme de formation qu'il l'avait
envisagé pour l'année à venir plus
largement quelles mesures entendez vous
prendre pour rétablir l'égalité de
traitement entre les agents des
collectivités je vous remercie madame
mise de votre réponse merci chers
collègues la parole est à mme marylise
lebranchu ministe de réforme de l'état
décentralisation de la fonction publique
merci à monsieur le président messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur le faire effectivement
sénateurs d'un très beau département
j'ai pu le constater le centre national
de la fonction publique d'abord il faut
le rappeler c'est un établissement
public à caractère administratif qui est
dédié à la formation des agents des
collectivités locales et pour assurer
cette formation ils disposent donc vous
l'avez dit dans votre question d'une
cotisation versée par l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales est assis
sur leur masse salariale
lorsque je suis arrivé en 2012 on a eu
une très longue conversation avec le
président du cnfpt et les représentants
des associations des maires en présence
de monsieur pélissard monsieur lebreton
en particulier sur les problèmes des
deux formations des agents et du fait
que c'était essentiel à la modération de
l'action publique territoriale et nous
avions convenu que le premier mouvement
de solidarité c'est d'augmenter
effectivement de revenir la cotisation
telle qu'elle était pourquoi parce que
les grandes villes nous sommes ici à
paris les grandes villes assure depuis
longtemps leur formation sur leurs
propres crédits sont qui est de même des
hésitations à y consacrer une part du
budget ce qui n'est pas le cas des
petites communes d'où notre orientation
de réaugmenter de permettre pardon
senneff parce que c'est lui qui en
décident de passer de 0,9 à 1-1 on l'a
fait au moment du projet de loi de
finances et rétablissement rétablissant
ainsi une solidarité possible alors je
n'ai pas les mêmes chiffres que vous est
peut-être que le problème vient de là
c'est que en décembre 2012 le cnfpt donc
fort de la confirmation de
l'augmentation puisqu'il ne pouvait le
faire qu'après le vote du projet de loi
de finances qui lui autorisait à
déplafonner ce qui t'a prélèvements
obligatoires sont des collectivités
territoriales a revu totalement sa
politique et donc compte tenu de
l'évolution des voitures et dans leur
consommation et de leur coûte y compris
assurance comprise ils ont pensé et
c'est la décision du conseil
d'administration que de rester à 0,18 du
kilomètre ne correspondaient pas à la
réalité qu'il valait mieux donc pour les
véhicules passés à 0 15 mai de 0,15 donc
du kilomètre mais dans un souci
d'adaptation de ses remboursements au
développement durable s'il y a co
voiturage alors le kilomètre sera
remboursé 0,20 dire qu'on estime que le
geste de covoiturage et le à la sueur
usure de la voiture ainsi utiliser
permet un remboursement à 0,20 en
revanche la décision a été prise de
rembourser totalement et c'est pour ça
que quand on écrit 20 20 euros du
premier kilomètre on est assez surpris
les uns les autres quand on lit cette
réponse en fait ce n'est pas tout à fait
comme ça que ça s'écrit dans la
délibération du cnfpt ces remboursements
total des frais réels ci a recours à des
transports en commun donc on présente
son billet et on est remboursé le petit
problème qu'il reste et qui n'est pas
totalement
couverts c'est la distance entre la
collectivité locale du lieu d'exercice
puisque on ne parle pas du domicile mais
de la collectivité et la gare est
effectivement là il peut y avoir une
discussion que le cnfpt pour que le
covoiturage de la mairie à la gare soit
également rembourser donc moi il me
semble que cette dernière disposition
sur les transports collectifs et de
qualité puisqu'elle permet aux agents
d'être remboursés en revanche si la
collectivité territoriale prête un
véhicule de service pour aller à ses
agents pour aller en formation il n'y a
pas du tout de remboursement parce qu'on
estime que quand il ya des véhicules de
service disponible et qu'on peut
détourner de leur fonction première qui
est servir les citoyens pour les
informations c'est que sans doute il ya
un parc assez important donc il faudrait
si vous le voulez soumettre à nouveau la
question des véhicules du service non
remboursés parce que là c'est non
remboursés au conseil d'administration
du cnfpt qui se réunira forcément comme
après chaque projet de loi de finances
après projet de loi de finances il
entérinera le fait que nous sommes
déterminés à garder le 20 % parce que
vous avez eu raison dans votre question
de souligner que c'est grâce à cette
augmentation que un certain nombre de
cursus de formation ont pu être réouvert
et c'est d'autant plus important que
dans le même temps avec la fonction
publique d'état nous et nous sommes en
train d'étudier l'évolution des
carrières des formations
professionnelles des échelons et
dégradent pour que les personnels d'état
puisse aller trouver équivalence de
travail dans les collectivités
territoriales serait dommage que les
collectivités territoriales ne les
agents n'est pas le même retour possible
grâce à des cursus de formation donc
voilà les chiffres tels que le président
du cnfpt les a confirmé ce matin
naturellement je lui ai demandé une note
de l'exposé des motifs si vous me
permettez cette expression non adapté un
établissement public mais adapté à ce
que nous connaissons ensemble dans un
parlement donc je vais demander une note
sur l'exposé des motifs qui vous sera
donné et rien n'empêche effectivement un
certain nombre de parlementaires ou de
représentants des collectivités
territoriales de demander révision
puisqu'au fond ça ne fait qu'un an et au
bout d'un an
à peine au bout d'un an même pas ça fait
janvier février mars avril mai juin
juillet
au bout de six mois on aura peut-être
pas suffisamment le recul mais au moment
de descendre on aura un an donc la
possibilité de faire évaluation hercules
et donc amélioration si besoin en était
voilà monsieur le sénateur ce que je
peux vous répondre au moment où le
président du cnfpt bien conscient de la
nécessité d'évaluer ce qu'ils ont décidé
en décembre 2012 au conseil
d'administration du cnfpt ce qui n'est
pas directement non plus de ma
responsabilité mais je ferai relais
aussi monsieur lefebvre
merci mamie nice pour un pour cette
réponse est pour cet engagement de fer
relais c'est vrai que j'avais l'occasion
d'auditionner et le président et le
directeur d'en cas de ce rapport il ya
peut-être une actualisation des chiffres
et je suis preneur de ces chiffres qui
vous ont été transmis tout récemment une
part est effectivement important que
cette révision puisse puisse se mettre
en place c'est vrai que la période est
quand même courte mais notamment pour
prendre en compte la spécificité des
communes rurales j'ai bien entendu votre
aux arguments sur le remboursement total
du billet de train sauf que lorsque vous
n'avez pas de garni au départ ni à
l'arrivée pour ces formations c'est ce
qui amène justement puisque la question
avait été
je relaie une question d'un de mes mère
qui est plutôt dans une commune
dominante rurale lorsqu'il met à
disposition ses véhicules je peux vous
dire que cette commune ne dispose pas
d'un parc énorme alors bon je crois que
c'est aussi des arrangements qu'il faut
trouver dans les communes y compris dans
les communes rurales mais je crois qu'il
faut je pense que le moment est
peut-être venu effectivement d'évaluer
un peu ce dispositif qui doit permettre
d'améliorer l'accès à l'information pour
tous merci merci mon cher collègue
l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale 2 me roland courteau monsieur le
ministre l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire